meanwhile israel israel appears to be
emerging as a diplomatic dark horse on
saturday prime minister naftali bennett
became the first world leader to meet
with vladimir putin since the invasion
began the surprise meeting was followed
by talks with ukrainian president
zielinski
bennett then traveled on to germany the
second time this week that the two
leaders met after schultz visited
jerusalem on wednesday to discuss a
diplomatic solution to the crisis
bennett has offered to act as a mediator
with israel maintaining good relations
with both russia and ukraine
for more let's bring in dw political
correspondent benjamin alvarez gruber
benjamin what do we know about the
meeting between chancellor schultz and
israel's naftali bennett
it was a 90 minutes talk that they had
we don't have more details of how these
talks between israel's prime minister
and the russian president vladimir putin
went but both of them underlined the
commitment and said that they will do
anything that they can so everything in
their strength and the war in ukraine as
soon as possible
why did bennett take the initiative to
mediate in this conflict
israel is in a quite interesting
position because they have warm and very
good relations both to kiev and also to
moscow but there are two interests here
contrasting interest when we look at
israel on one side of course it wants to
belong to the western alliance one to
show itself close to the us but on the
other side there's a known security risk
as well as it has a military cooperation
with russia in syria so that's why many
see israel and zelensky also ask israel
to try to be a mediator and try to find
common ground between russia and ukraine
and of course both leaders so israel's
prime minister bennett and olaf trolls
will be closely following the third
round of t peace talks between russia
and ukraine that is expected to take
place on monday
benjamin alvarez gruber thanks very much
turkey's president erdogan has held a
phone call with russian counterpart
vladimir putin the turkish leader was
expected to urge putin to agree to a
cease-fire in ukraine turkey also has
close relations with both moscow and
kiev but recently moved to limit the
passage of russian warships into the
black sea
under the montreux convention ankara can
block ships from passing through its
straits during wartime but can't prevent
them from returning to their home ports
dw's dorian jones is in istanbul forest
dorian
what do you know about that call between
uh president erdogan and putin
well the call has finished uh but
there's been no readout of what actually
happened in those talks neither moscow
nor ankara released any information as
of yet but uh turkish president uh
rejected one's uh spokesman ibrahim
cullen speaking to reporters on saturday
said that erdogan in those talks will
call for an end to hostilities by russia
and failing that at least to haul these
growing international calls for a
ceasefire to allow humanitarian
corridors to be established to into
these besieged cities all across ukraine
where then humanitarian aid can be
delivered and civilians can exit and
that will be the message from erdogan
apparently will was delivered to putin
along with the fact that according to
cullen the turkish position is there can
be no resolution to this conflict until
there's a
cessation of uh of conf of the conflict
and uh turkey is trying to position
itself as as a possible mediator ever
since the conflict started ankara has
been trying to position itself to
mediate between both ukraine and russia
as president erdogan has close relations
with both those countries presidents but
as of yet uh putin has rebuffed those
efforts by turkey
could these latest developments be seen
as turkey taking aside i mean as you say
the nato country has really close
relations with ukraine and russia
well that's the question that i mean
this conflict really has put turkey in a
very tight position uh he's been walking
a tight rope trying to balance relations
with both sides uh on the one side
turkey hasn't imposed uh sanctions
against russia and has in fact rejected
them uh saying that they are
counterproductive uh and also turkey has
not closed his airspace to russian civil
planes despite most of his western
allies doing that but at the same time
turkey has taken a tough stance against
russia it's closed its istanbul
bossarous waterway to russian ships on
top of that it has been supplying a lot
of sophisticated weapons to ukraine in
particular it's uh noteworthy uh drones
which have impacted russian military in
a very big and significant way so i
think that their expectation is that
ultimately turkey is siding with ukraine
and i think turkey's western allies will
be looking at this as a possibility of
breaching turkey's relationship with
russia and the u.s deputy secretary of
state wendy sherman was in turkey on
saturday holding talks over ukraine
dw's dorian jones for us in istanbul
thank you
and in other news u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken is in moldova to pledge
american support to the country which
has nearly
seen nearly a quarter of a million
refugees from ukraine pouring in during
his visit lincoln also said that the
united states was working actively on a
deal with poland to supply ukraine with
fighter jets
tens of thousands of people around the
world have been protesting against the
russian invasion of ukraine
demonstrations condemning russia's
president putin took place in cities
across the united states as well as in
paris london and other european capitals
with no end in sight to the war the
number of refugees keeps climbing the un
says the total figure of people who fled
ukraine has now topped one and a half
million it calls it the fastest growing
refugee crisis since world war ii